LAW TO MAKE SURE THAT
>> YOU'RE FOCUSINGT HERE
BUT ONE IS RUSSIA'S INSITO REGI.
SEVERODONETSK HAS FALLEN
OVERNIGHT MANY MISSILES WERE
SSA SAYSHE
ING? JAKE, LET'S NOT CONFUSE THE
H TEGIC.EN IT  PUTIN'S TEGIC 'S
Y POEDGIC OBJECTIVS TO ROM THE .
THE STRAC POP SIGN
THAT PUTIN WILL NOT SUCCEED IN
WH AVE
WA'S TRI TO DI A
SU
SHOW GREATERNI
STRENGTH THAN INMEMORY UKRAINE T
REPEL THE RUSSIAYOU THINK THE AO
KY THIS G
OF RECT PROVOCATION
AGAINST THE ING OFEE, EVER
SI BATTLE FOR  AND THIS
NDUKRAINE,AT THE OCCASIONA
LAUNCHED MISSIATISTANC
BASICALLY TO TRIPLE.
EYMENT
THERE ARE REPORTS TH STRUCK A
PUOTHER TH RI UKRAINIANS.HE GD N
RUSSIAN GOLDMPTS
THEY SAID IT WOUEVONOMY E RUBLE
ARG.WHEN SANCTIONSOING
TO STA THAT
THE  PRESINTHAVERO AA
THAT IS THE SECONDOS
LUCR RUSSIAFTER ENERGY.
BILLION A YEAR.
MOST OF  IWI7 IES.CUG THAT OFF,Y
ACCE T9 BI
SIIFBE JAKE, HI TSTART ININES
PROFOUND IMPACT ON RUS
EVEN AS ITL REVENUES
R PRICES, IT'SBLE ND THEBECAUSET
NEEDSERNIZE DEFENSE SECTOR THEH
MEANS OVER TIMOF THESEAREAS IS N
DICTIOHESINOMYL
SHRINKY  T% R.BLE HAS BEEN PRO
MAR S E PRODUCTS THAWEHEHE
E NOW
DWINDLED.
RUNSY WHAT THEY'RE. OF LIVING FR
RUSSIANS IS DROPPING.
ALL OF THIS IS HAVING AN EFFECT
200,00, AMONG THE MOST
ED, WORK WILLIN
THE MOST T
INDUSTRIES, HAVE LEFT.
MANY FOREIGNER THOSE
EFT.
THIE
ACCUMULATES, ACC, MULATE WAS AOU
OFY
REED HOME IN PRINE, MY
UNDERSTAG  THERE MIGHT BE
ANOTHER PRISONER SWAP IN
CNN REPORTS THERE
DISI AND YOUND
ENBI AIFAVORF A SWAP, GRINER
BOUT.G
HAV HIGHER PRIORITY
G SURE AMERICANS WHO E BEING LE
ININNCLUDES
IN A NUMBER OF OTHERRIES.OK
THEM.R PRIO DIALOGUE WITH A TESS
I CAN'T COMMENT IN ANY DET EXCE.
>> SHEHITE HS
PRESIDENT BIDE
MEETING WIHEDI
IN RIYADTH WIL
INCLUDE THDOM'S CROW
PRKE AND MBS A PARIA
FOF URNALIST, L KHASHOGGI O WROT
"T."
C OIL BREAKING  COMES TO SAUDI
ARABIA, WHAT WE SAID IS WE
NEEDED TATTH
REAKT
IT MREFLECTED
VALUES.
BUT RUPTURE
T
F LU
WHEN IT COMES TOONSHIP BROADLY,
CRITICAL TOPI
N ONE OF THEWARS AND ATRASTIESN
.ACCOUNTS THE
WORST HUMANITARIITOND THAT'S SA
SOMETHIN EAGS
BEEN ABSOLUTELCRG WHAT WVEN'T HA
EIGHT YEARS, WHICH I
TRUCS BEEN EXTENDED.
THE GUNSE BEEN SILENCED.EN
OF KHASHOGGI.
SURE TH
ACCOUNTABILINDCLEAR
THOR HIS
MURDER WAS PUT OUT IN PUBLICWIT
WE ININGD
N TOE SU
THOSE CRITICEM FROM ESS
THIRD LUDING T
WE'VE US TTES,ENALED
LIKE 70 TIMEE
WE PUT A TOGR,E WORKING  A ALLFW